yo what's up man i gotta get these
little legs home looks like you wanted
it to shut down
corner oh hell yeah it's a receiver
[Music]
hey yo what's this bear's name
the corners have captured our struggling
qb's we need our top receiver to bail
them out again
okay fine i'll go for real though i
can't do it because i'm the only one who
received aaron's nightly ramblings hey
devonta tonight we're going to prove how
the cia killed jfk
i should go dk can tackle anything one
time
you play offense nuke can't got a thing
that's okay
he's so cool i got to thank super guys
what to say mike i refuse to help
but only because my feelings are hurt
this may be a job for our new weapon
let's just say it's going to be
booming it's a literal ticking time bomb
set me free look we'll never be truly
kidnapped unless we're kids at home let
jones
run trust us i'm almost free oh ow
ow
[Music]
yo i'm robbie anderson and this is sir
purr yeah we call him that
i didn't know but sir purr is a panther
not a bear
now he's my best friend and we going
adventures together we saw crimes
his dope was full and now you know and
knowing is half the battle